[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] Please tell us about yourself.
[Shubin:] My name is Andrey Shubin.
I was born in the Soviet Union,
in Shevchenko, Kazakhstan.
This city is now called Aktau.
After the collapse of the Soviet Union,
my parents and I moved to Russia.
We lived in a small town in southern Russia
where I graduated from
high school.
After that, I entered the Moscow State University
of Fine Chemical Technologies
where I majored in biotechnology.
After graduation, I entered the graduate school
of the Institute of Molecular Genetics of the Academy
of Sciences.
I defended my thesis
and then worked for a short time
at the Gamaleya Research Institute.
And then I came here
where I took up a position
as a postdoctoral researcher
at the Craig Hunter Laboratory
in the Department of Molecular
and Cellular Biology
at Harvard University.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] How did you choose your major,
and why did you choose biology?
[Shubin:] Thank you,
that's quite an interesting question,
because all my life...
during my school years,
I didn't take biology seriously.
I always wanted to be a chemist,
so I gave special attention to this discipline.
I took extra classes
in order to enter a good university
that offered a chemistry program.
I succeeded.
I vividly remember one episode.
I was demonstratively doing
my chemistry homework
or solving some extra
chemistry problems in a biology class.
The biology teacher
was also our homeroom teacher.
I don't know if this system
even exists in American schools.
I mean, this teacher supervises
a particular class.
So, our homeroom teacher
was also our biology teacher.
I vividly remember her words.
She said,
“Andrei, you should study biology,
it will come in handy for you”.
I just...
Her words amazed me.
I said,
“How can biology come in handy for me?
It's so boring”.
However, things turned out
to be not as I expected.
When I entered the institute...
The thing is we had a major,
yet we had some room for maneuver.
The first four years...
We could change our minds during the first 2 years
of our undergraduate studies.
Needless to say,
I was so passionate about chemistry,
and I was eager to get my hands on
some lab glassware as soon as possible
and start synthesizing something.
Therefore, I volunteered to work
at the laboratory
when I was a freshman.
However, I realized very quickly
that it wasn’t my cup of tea.
It was a real shock.
And I am grateful to those people
who accepted me
as the chemistry lab assistant,
because they gave me
some very good advice.
They told me,
“You know, we think molecular biology
might be more suitable
for you”.
I said, “Well, let's give it a try”.
So, when I was a sophomore,
I started working
at the protein engineering lab
of the Institute of Molecular Genetics
under the guidance of a brilliant researcher
Ilya Valerievich Demidyuk.
I worked with him for almost 10 years.
I mean, we worked together
while I completed my bachelor's
and master's degree programs,
as well as my postgraduate program.
It is not uncommon for the Russian system.
However, I know that in the United States
you usually change the laboratory,
which may be more reasonable,
but that's another story.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] What are you studying now?
[Shubin:] At the end of my master's degree program
and during my postgraduate program,
I really wanted to become a biologist
and work with the whole organism.
That’s what I did
after I got my postdoctoral position,
because here I work with C. elegans.
C. elegans is a small nematode or worm.
And we study how they adapt
to environmental factors.
They do this by changing
their gene expression.
Gene expression means
that the protein
encoded in the RNA fragment
accumulates in different amounts
depending on the animal’s physiological state.
In turn, the animal’s physiological state
depends on environmental factors.
Using the example of different animals,
in particular this model organism,
the nematode C. elegans,
it has been shown that certain
environmental factors,
such as changes in temperature
or exposure to pathogens,
lead to a change in this protein balance
and other molecules encoded in the genome.
Speaking about other molecules,
I mean those RNA molecules
that don't encode protein.
In addition, it was found
that these altered states
of gene expression can be transmitted
from one generation to the next.
And these things can happen for 4-6
and, in some cases,
even dozens of generations.
Thus, the hypothesis arose
that this transmission
of gene expression states
caused by environmental factors
can serve as an adaptation mechanism
that gives offspring an advantage,
which means that they feel better
and reproduce more actively.
As a result, they can have more offspring
in changed environmental
conditions.
And this mechanism,
which lasts only
for several generations,
can be considered as something
between the adaptation
of an organism during its life,
that is, its physiological
adaptation to the environment,
and an adaptation that is caused
by such factors as, for example,
DNA mutations.
Once such a mutation occurs,
it gets fixed,
and the organism and its offspring,
roughly speaking, can't get rid of it.
In the case of this epigenetic
inheritance mechanism,
which is not accompanied
by a change in the DNA sequence,
we can imagine a malleable state
where we can inherit
something potentially useful,
but if environmental factors change,
we’ll be able to leave
and reset this heredity.
Whether this is true,
what genes are responsible for this,
what mechanisms are responsible for the way
gene expression states are transmitted
from one generation to the next
is, basically,
the subject of our research
at Professor Hunter’s laboratory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:]
What is the most difficult part of your job?
[Shubin:] Let me answer this question
from the point of view
of someone working in the field
of fundamental biology,
since there are a lot of branches of biology.
Also, different biologists
have different goals.
My goal is not to develop
some technology.
some drug.
My goal is to understand
how nature works,
that is, how certain mechanisms work,
and, of course,
to choose the right experimental model,
to decide which direction to take,
which experiments to do,
which approach to use,
especially in the context of my career
as a postdoctoral researcher,
given the fact that this position
is limited in time.
So, we need to solve all these problems
within a certain time
and get a certain formal result,
because if you want to move on,
you have to publish your results
in such a way
that your colleagues believe in them,
including those colleagues
who want to see you
as an assistant professor
at some university
or institute.
Your results should appear
to your colleagues
to be really significant.
It's quite difficult to do this
in fundamental biology
and, probably, in any other branch of biology.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] In your opinion, what are the most
significant discoveries in the
20th and 21st centuries that determined
the development of biology as a science?
[Shubin:] Yes, that's a very broad question.
The thing is that almost everything
that ever happened in biology
happened in the 20th century,
since the sciences that we know,
such as immunology and biochemistry,
emerged as independent disciplines.
Many of those sciences
emerged in the 20th century,
including molecular biology
and molecular genetics.
Generally speaking,
the 20th century began
with the rediscovery of Mendel's laws,
which had a huge impact
on the development of biology,
and this influence can hardly
be overestimated.
Later,
deoxyribonucleic acid was identified
as a carrier of genetic
information,
which, of course,
was also a significant discovery.
After that, gene structure
was determined,
including the way it works,
the genetic code,
and so on and so forth.
I mean, it’s hard to say
what was the most important...
Maybe this, because it helped us
understand how nature works,
and, of course, how we can use it,
since biotechnology emerged
right after the development
of fundamental biology.
Its achievements in the 20th century
are simply amazing.
It’s hard to imagine
how much has been done
by these scientists.
Even though I majored in biotechnology
and have been working
in this field throughout my career,
it’s impossible even for me
to imagine that.
It has completely changed our lives.
Speaking about the 21st century,
of course, we should mention the fact
that genome editing technology
has been commercialized
or at least become part
of everyday laboratory work.
In addition,
I think the development
of high-throughput sequencing methods
has also had a huge impact…
it means we can now read the genomes
of the organisms
we are interested in.
In addition, we can read
the genomes of a single cell.
Also, we can read
the transcriptomes of a single cell,
that is, all the RNA molecules
that can be synthesized
from a genomic RNA template.
As a result, our understanding
of the mechanisms
of organism development
and disease development
has improved significantly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] Could you tell us how the vaccines work?
[Shubin:] I would like to explain
how BioNTech's mRNA vaccine works.
Supporting information
will be shown on this slide.
The vaccine from BioNTech
is an mRNA vaccine,
which means it doesn’t contain
the antigen itself.
That is,
there are no structural fragments of the virus
in this vaccine.
It contains a genetic construct
that encodes the spike protein
of the coronavirus,
that is, the fragment of the coronavirus
to which effective antibodies
are produced,
including neutralizing antibodies.
These antibodies are capable
of blocking the ability
of the virus to infect cells.
These genetic constructs
or mRNA molecules
are packed in special
synthetic lipophilic particles
that allow the vaccine
to be delivered to the cell.
When the vaccine enters the cell,
these particles open
and release it into the cell,
into the cytoplasm.
The RNA molecules are used
by the cellular machinery
to synthesize the antigen.
That is, translation occurs:
this messenger RNA
is used as a template,
and antigen synthesis occurs
with the help of ribosomal complexes.
This antigen is then processed
by special cell machinery
in order to create
small fragments of it,
which then appear on the cell surface
together with special molecules,
histocompatibility complexes.
This is where immune cells
come into play.
All four of them are shown here.
The T-helper recognizes
this antigen fragment
as a foreign fragment
that can't...
that was not synthesized
in the host organism.
The T-helper is then activated.
Cytotoxic T-killers are also activated.
These cells are able
to kill other cells
that have the antigen on their surface,
including those cells
that are infected with the virus.
In addition, T-helpers activate B-cells
that are responsible
for the production of antibodies.
As I already mentioned,
in the case of this vaccine,
these antibodies have
a pronounced neutralizing ability,
that is, they can effectively prevent
the infection of cells
with a virus that is in the extracellular
space.
Thus, since this vaccine is very effective,
it can significantly reduce
the mortality from COVID-19.
It can also significantly reduce
the risk of infection.
And even if you get sick,
it will probably be just a mild case.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] What areas in biology do you consider
the most promising now?
[Shubin:] This conventional view does exist,
but I think some experts
would disagree with it.
Neurobiology is very popular today.
Indeed, it is developing
at a very fast pace.
In addition, we have some subfields
of computer biology,
computational biology,
and bioinformatics,
but as a geneticist and molecular biologist
I can say that these disciplines
are extremely promising,
especially in terms of the development
of new technologies in healthcare,
including new drugs.
Therefore, it’s hard for me
to answer this question,
since modern biology has a lot of
different subfields,
and all of them emerged
to help us study nature
and serve humanity.
All of them are developing
very rapidly,
and all of them can be of great benefit to us.
Thus, all of them are promising.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] What are some opportunities in
the field of biology for those who speak Russian?
[Shubin:] It's true that English
is the main language in biology,
and I think the same is true
of other sciences.
As for the Russian language,
it really helped me
when I was interested
in the history of science.
For example, it was a great surprise for me
to learn that the fundamental
evolutionary ideas
were formulated not only
by Western scientists,
but also by scientists who worked
in Russia or the Russian Empire.
And, of course, it was very interesting
to read their original works
and to follow their line of thought.
In other words,
I think that for an English-speaking researcher
who doesn’t speak Russian
it would be more difficult
to obtain such information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] Does knowing not only the Russian
language, but also the culture matter?
[Shubin:] Of course, since modern science teams
are international teams,
it means that if you speak other languages
and are familiar with other cultures,
it will be much easier for you
to communicate and interact with your teammates,
because you can understand
the context embedded in culture.
As far as I am concerned,
I can say that the vast majority
of my social circle
and my colleagues are Americans.
However, even though
my English is quite good,
when it comes to their cultural layer
and cultural context,
I have a hard time.
Sometimes I ask my colleagues to explain
what certain things mean,
and it turns out that they referred
to some cartoon they watched
when they were kids.
Needless to say, I didn’t watch those cartoons,
or I watched them in Russian,
so I have completely different associations.
I mean, if you speak Russian,
you can read and watch things,
you know the context,
you can crack a good joke
to defuse a situation
and become a great colleague.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] What is the word of the year in biology?
[Shubin:] That’s a very broad question.
It’s very difficult to say
what is the most important thing
in biology.
Let me name a word
that was relevant in 2020,
2021 and 2022.
I want to talk about the impact
biology has
on our daily lives,
and I can say that “vaccine”
is still the word of the year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] What is your opinion on
the ethical aspects of gene editing?
[Shubin:] Indeed, genome editing
technology gives us
new possibilities for treating diseases
and, let's say,
modifying organisms.
As for humans,
of course, the main question
is whether we could modify something
in humans in order to improve them,
or whether we could tweak the genomes
of human embryos
to improve human health,
and so on and so forth.
However, as far as I know,
some of those researchers
that are trying to improve
the genome editing technology
have some doubts
whether this technology could be used,
for example, to correct defects
grounded in embryonic development.
The main problem with this technology
is the so-called off-target genome editing.
It means that in addition
to the intended modifications
you may also have
some unintended modifications.
Since the genome is such a big thing,
these modifications may go unnoticed,
or they may appear to have
no bearing
on the development of the organism,
but we are not sure about that.
We are not sure
about the possible consequences either.
Therefore, speaking about
the development of this technology,
the main goal at this point
is to increase its accuracy.
We need to be confident
that this technology
will allow us to have
the intended modifications.
As far as I am concerned,
I think that at the current stage
of development of this technology,
we can use it to treat diseases.
For example, if a person
has an oncological disorder
and can be cured with the help
of this technology,
I think we should calculate
the risks involved.
This person may want
to be cured of their oncology,
even though they realize
that something
may go wrong in the future.
However, at least this person
may have a future,
and they can make a decision
based on those probabilities.
As for the embryo,
besides the problem of the accuracy
of this technology,
there is also an ethical issue,
and such ethical issues
can often be very unexpected.
Let me give you an example.
There are people out there who suffer
from hearing loss.
We’ve been living side by side
with such people for many centuries,
and such people have existed
for many centuries.
And they have developed
their own culture,
which is related
to their hearing loss.
Accordingly, in modern society,
some people believe
that there is no need to treat hearing loss,
and people who suffer from this condition
are considered to be as normal
as those who don’t have this problem.
In addition, people who are told
that their kids
can be cured of hearing loss
may not approve of that,
because they believe that in this case their kids
will not be able to continue
their cultural traditions,
and, as a result, the cultural background
accumulated by those people
will be lost over time.
Thus, we are in an interesting situation
where something that is considered
to be a disease by some people
is not recognized as a disease by others,
and it’s not clear whether parents
can decide
for their future kid
whether to treat him of this condition or not,
that is, whether to correct
this condition or not.
I’m not an ethicist.
For example,
this case
makes me a bit confused…
I mean, I don’t know
what to do in this situation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] LIGHTNING ROUND QUESTIONS!
Books or movies?
[Shubin:] Books.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:]
What is your favorite Russian book or movie?
[Shubin:] That’s a very hard question.
There are a lot of Russian books that I like.
For example, all the books
written by the Strugatsky brothers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:]
What Russian scientist inspired you the most?
[Shubin:] Mechnikov.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:]
What are your three tips for young scientists?
[Shubin:] Don’t rely on authority too much.
Don’t be afraid to build
social connections
because that’s extremely
important in science.
And the third thing is to believe in yourself.
We are capable of doing much more
than we can imagine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[Text:] "Sputnik" or "Moderna"?
[Shubin:] Good question.
Both vaccines are very effective
as shown by time and their prevalence.
Those people who are choosing
between the Sputnik and Moderna vaccines
should know that the Sputnik vaccine
is based on adenovirus technology.
It’s quite a well-known technology,
its properties are well-known too,
and several other vaccines have already
been developed based on this platform,
including those made
by the Gamaleya Institute,
and they also proved to be effective.
As for the Moderna vaccine,
I have no doubts about its effectiveness,
but this technology is the newest,
and I hope that in the future
we’ll be able to...
I mean, doctors will be able to recommend
the right vaccines depending
on their patients’ health.
I think this is the best approach
when it comes to choosing vaccines.
Well, given the ongoing war and pandemic,
I would recommend you
get those vaccines
that are available in your region.
[MUSIC PLAYING]